alright that was more like it that first
intro was a faux intro anyways hi guys
thanks everyone for tuning in today
thinking about live live on Twitch
YouTube GameSpot so we're gonna play an
anime game cuz I like anime so it's a
good excuse to play an anime game but
recently sort our sword art online fatal
bullet that follows the GGO or gun Gale
online arc or in that timeframe came out
and so we're gonna check it out I'm on
the left or well depends on your this is
my character that other character over
here is my office system who I've named
Mason I kind of regret that name anyways
she's kind of like a blade from
Xenoblade if you play Xenoblade she also
does my banking I've given her an
allowance to buy stuff but yeah she
pretty much is like a helper I gave her
five thousand I don't know if that's a
lot or a little
but yeah so she also fights in combat
with me I could change some of the
skills in this game are kind of like
weapon based so I forget what I gave her
give her something decent I think I
prioritized healing for her and then for
me I think I'm using like a submachine
gun right now and a assault rifle just
because that's what I've gotten like
legendary or epic wise this game is like
an RPG who hit like a lot of systems and
like a lot of items to deal with and
whatnot like I got all these things I've
got uh appraised things there's just a
lot going on I try to make my character
look like here's though the girl not
actually realizing that Kyoto was in the
game
so it's kind of awkward when he talks to
me but yeah you know that's fine
you know Thanks Chief Bill Gates Bob for
life thanks for coming in anime in the
streets hentai in the sheet says jeff
sign sure but yeah anime Mondays on
Tuesday yeah so it got bumped yeah I was
gonna play it yesterday but then into
the breach came out and it was a kind of
a cool little game so we ended up
playing that instead so here's my status
I can increase more points I actually
have no idea what I'm doing in terms of
like the points here I know you do need
certain state oh let me get rid of
myself so you guys can see all these
stats I know you need certain stats to
quit weapons or like equip certain
equipment so I don't know I thought Dex
was a good thing no idea vitality seems
safe you know and I just put enough
strength to kind of um carry stuff in
one on maybe we will use a sword at some
point yeah I creature I just noticed
that so anyways I'll bring myself back
up later when we're in combat I have no
idea what I'm doing here but if you guys
have tips feel free to put them in the
end of the chatham just be myself more
life because you know more life is
always a good thing here here's my
equipment right now I'm rocking a epic
drak l Scirocco SMG this thing would be
pretty good I guess I guess we could we
could potentially use handgun just cuz
it's got so much damage I did not
realize Green was like the high I guess
Green's the highest tier it's legendary
which like I was like what
but yeah I don't have a sniper right now
and I am about to fight a dungeon boss I
feel like but uh yeah so here's some of
the stuff let me quickly show you if you
want to see all your sao buddies will go
to Kyoto's room to check out david
Norrell says it is a learning curve
don't beat yourself up about it over it
oh thanks yeah there's just a lot of
there was way more systems in this game
than I thought there was gonna be which
is cool you know like there's more depth
than I thought
yeah we got you know we got our girl
here asana and Yui you know mom and
daughter she can make you outfits there
are a lot of outfits I kind of just show
you some of them real quick let's get to
the good ones I guess I think I have
three-piece suit anyways this thing
looks sick I don't know how the hell I
get this but I need this in my life
that one's alright Queens dress sure
yeah so like once you get these patterns
you can essentially get asana to make
you gear this is likely fuzz gear this
one's like you ease seen on wait that's
not seen on seen on I think that one was
Austin uh this is cute though obviously
so yeah she's got a bunch that she can
make for you I'm not gonna go through
all of them here's our boy Kyoto stud
got old man pervert Klein the funny
thing is he hits on like the AI in this
game you got Elizabeth the blacksmith
she can enhance a weapon I haven't
really gotten into this either yet
because I wasn't sure exactly if I
wanted to do it on any of my weapons yet
I was kind of confused I kill I kill he
appraises a team of you're like an ID to
items so like I don't know we'll just an
ID this sword I guess it's epic you know
so that seems pretty good damage 189 I
don't know maybe it's kind of a low rank
weapon though you also have like
equipment that you wear so what is this
another epic beret so far I've only
gotten Berets and like ribbons anyways
yeah so you get that while you're
playing the game so why don't we one
only go do that so if you're curious
what leaf it looks like that's leaf uh I
don't remember leaf ax and gun gale arc
but you know to fail is a learning
experience this is true
you got silica usually her little
dragons around but maybe not in this
case they're seen on you know one of the
main characters in the gun Gale arc
anyways can show you some of the other
bedroom this is where the magic happens
I guess so there's all these other rooms
like squadron pvp and PVE there's like
little additional quests you can get
which is pretty cool you can also
message Kyoto and tell them and join
your party yeah that's that's true
Christian I haven't done that yet either
I probably should to be honest just so
that we can kind of get all right so we
got a bounty thing there also like so
normally I just bring my office system
which again I called nee-chan
and then I bring our childhood friend
Yuri ha who is how they who brought us
into the game essentially so yeah Thank
You max we've cooked for the kind of
like the breakdown of the stats there I
just don't I like I'm sure like what you
know obviously some weapons are gonna
net more from from certain stats and I
don't know what I want to I'm no idea
what I want to play you got the squadron
treasure so we're just picking up all
these like little side quests that we
can do we're still in the first area the
like hub world that we're in right now
is the SPC glocken but then we're gonna
go to the remnant waste is like kind of
like the first area ish where you you
know you'll fight stuff in the world and
then there's also dungeons I believe I
have one dungeon I guess we don't have
any requests from that there's actually
a lot talking this game to which
depending on if you like that or not
because of the RP and whatnot it's good
sometimes I kind of just spam through it
because some of the like you get two
answers that you can um pick from and
sometimes they almost feel similar it's
like I don't know it's pretty fun but
the only bad part is you can't do story
co-op or even go to the battlefield with
a pal oh that's really I haven't tried
too much of the multiplayer yet
Christian Lander I know that you can
like queue up multiplayer rooms in the
the lobby here where we're gonna get to
run to here in a second so I I think
I've seen this next boss and he looks
pretty tough and it looks like this next
boss would probably be
pretty good to have like more range
weapons than the weapons I have but
we'll see if we can deal with it and
hopefully not get rekt now let me show
you guys a lobby real quick before we go
into the remnant wasteland so we can I
think there's a couple more quests I
didn't pick up just so I can show you
guys the quests Jeff sign says Kyoto is
useless boy I'm not gonna say that other
word asana is the best build your team
to heal and buff and John wick
everything uh yeah that's probably true
I have my Arfa system or nee-chan
nice on prioritizing healing I don't
have I just Yuri how seems to do a lot
of damage so I just let her do her thing
so there's these a little like you know
kill quests and whatnot there's also a
shop that you can buy you know gadgets
and guns from so you know like we could
buy wedding ring oh also I think the
outfit and that I'm wearing is just
something you get as a part of the
collectors so I have the collectors
that's why I have that um kinda like
that Isana looking arm where I think
it's from AOL if I'm not mistaken I
haven't a three-piece suit if you guys
want to see me John wick some stuff that
actually seems topical where's that
three-piece suit alright let's go John
wick some stuff I'm sorry that I have a
beret on but that's just kind of how
it's gonna be you know alright it's time
to go John wick hello weebs what's up
thanks for tuning in I can't say your
name there's too many letters each your
loadout should be based on your skills
yeah so again so many systems I just
kind of pick some skills from my weapons
do you get your DLC items I believe I
got them ace McLean I think that's what
I was wearing
yeah exactly question why is Yuna there
I thought she died from cancer yeah I'm
confused by that to rise Morgan I'm not
sure if this is just because I was
thinking I was like okay when his mother
okay so I haven't read the light novels
I've only watched the anime so I have I
don't know timeframe wise like where
where this is set in because like if
it's gun Gail like she wasn't mother
wasn't that arc before like he wouldn't
have met her too until died so this is
the this is the combat I have four
skills at the bottom right there that I
can use I just use the speed up I think
where's this facility okay so you can
see on the map there that there's like
other worlds and places to go to
there's definitely higher level monsters
than these ones you also have this like
special weapon that we got from getting
our like ARPA system it's like a whip
that you can also like glide on just
like clinging on to stuff it also does
damage which is good I actually probably
should have got more ammo beforehand
also they have like weak spots that you
want to hit like red is obviously like a
critical spot so you want to try to hit
those I have like I have moves like this
like kind of - charge I also have like a
like a I didn't do it Oh run one like
this sliding shooting move and then then
have a tactical row roll I guess we
should be killing those guys cuz we have
quest for it yeah there's like a bunch
of stuff over there there's another
dungeon that we did to the right hand
side but we'll just go on to the left
here and hope that I'm high enough level
to do it I think I am not sure though oh
yeah we want to kill those oh okay
getting sticky here more stuff than I
thought there'd be hey my teammates do
something that's cuz I'm also like the
fly and stuff you can hit them like
you'll drag them to the ground with the
whip thing grappling hook I can see you
so I knock him down there and then he
gets crit the whole time it's good it
does kind of get annoying that I'll be
like yelling maybe that's just me so I
knew fast point when you check out this
lab and hope that we can beat the boss I
don't know I could be too low level hard
to say I use sore k-dog seven a day he
says I use sword and submachine gun and
slash pistol how you liking the sword
you know like you want to channel your
real inner cute oh you use sword and
like handgun or whatever or SMG I guess
Gary G the game is out it's been out
since last Friday the 23rd so yeah it
definitely launched last Friday someone
earlier said they were like level 60
which is like pretty good I'm only level
like 20 or 19 oh my purse do a crapload
of damage so okay cool I didn't get rid
of Y oh she's dead she could be dead
oh I feel good they do so much damage
snipers I don't know if my sniper rifle
would do that much damage but
can also see you like where they're
gonna fire and stuff like that I also
picked a like a manly your voice I guess
also sorry if my aim is not so great try
to feather it a little bit get me hit
here someone said it's 25 and easy to
kill okay Oh Mike one is kind of like 20
so I think it'd be okay alright let's
get back there sorry sword can do decent
damage if you run then attack oh these
are like the suicide bomber guys yeah be
careful
oh that's silly I didn't think it would
hit me after the fact I thought if I
killed him he's gone
but there's also like a healing bullet
thing I don't have any quick but I think
that why our food system has it I'm
saying definitely want to try to create
them not like what I'm doing which is
missing the crits do play as Kirito you
make your own avatar said he say
well that guy's new I never seen that
guy where's your weak spot
oh it's part your eyeball yeah so which
is awkward but you can redo your avatar
because I could've did that forehand I
don't even with male character I guess
that's not what I expected yeah what are
you guys this favorite weapon for those
that have played do you guys want to see
anything in particular I can try
switching weapons but like I said for
some reason and I don't know if it's
just because it's like what I've been
using but mainly I've been getting
dropped like SMGs and ARS sometimes
swords and I can't tell if that's just
because that's what I've been playing
and the game favours you know kind of
what you've been playing also I should
be looking out for treasure boxes like
they are even a room here wonder if
there's like a map of this place
probably is fast travel okay
there's something up here that's fine
oh he's got shotgun oh it's yeah it's a
weapon type - I haven't used whoops
are you going to be the one doing the
review and when can we strike the final
score I don't know if we're actually
reviewing this game Michael so I just
wanted to cover the game because I
personally like sword art so just
playing so you guys can get a taste of
it to see if you know maybe it's
something you guys want to pick up oh
here's a treasure chest see what we get
out of it nothing I guess
oh we got some anti material bullets
sangfroid i guess you think there'd be
more yes I know that there's oh I didn't
get the crouch crap this is when you
want a sniper URI huh please kill them
yeah I'm down
no wait am i down yeah I'm down that
kind of hurts so bad oh no she's down -
it's okay your house real like really
buff I should be dodging on the oh I was
gonna say like normally it tells you
like it has an indicator and you should
probably stash away like that I probably
just get closer right oh ok or you can
just fall off the planet there I wonder
if you have to beat these guys first to
get like something to show up yeah ok
that makes sense yeah there is a co-op
in the like there's like a multiplayer
that you could get into yeah so whoever
gave me that tip earlier that said I
should have probably had some type of
ranged weapon yeah good shout probably
how is that Oh
what that guy was dead all right
okay request that's good there's
estimated you're not sure your home
Magon one go burst firing wait for the
best shot you trying
oh crap that's easy for you to say I
don't know it's hard for me to treat
this like a real game I guess but I will
try to take that advice you definitely
need to do that though against like the
other like fake players though that you
PvP against so that's pretty good advice
I'm just not as a depth to playing
something I don't even know what I got I
don't feel like the treasury's boxers
ever feel like they're as worth as I
feel like they should be this is
probably why I should just go rocket
launcher and then just hope that I can
get Splash Damage instead of like oh oh
fell off
[Music]
I know that you don't get punished for
that though like Nissan why Oh where's
the other sniper oh right what's bad is
that she's my healer I don't know what
the hell your house is doing she chillin
how I wish there was like like an active
reload thing like gears that would be
kind of cool most annoying came with a
game so far yeah
OSHA's is the boss I think it is I gotta
find a weak spot I think he just drops
up hit little bomb to get our speed up
oh he's got like a beam rain thing
that's why his weak spot yeah
oh she ran back that way I guess all
right she's having a feeling bullet
which is good no idea buzz blow actually
nor do I know how big the blast I did
was I'm assuming it's not that big
show me your eyeball
what sucks is none of my skills right
now really helped me
except for maybe tactical role Oh
just dancing around some bombed with the
art
you guys supposed to keep moving but I
just don't want that laser beam the
queue up cuz then we won't have any
cover feel like that blaster this is a
super big right of our a our boss so
we're gonna have to go good ol SMG
pulleys thrown out something different
now
I'd really like a sniper right now
I want to say we're doing okay for right
now but
no definitely not standing we hunt do
you think he can break the wall you
would think you would be able to right
my question is am I gonna run out of
ammo who knows 467 bullets left
awkward
not cool man
mistakes are made to increase your party
you have to press start okay I'll read
that in second oh crap
hold on we're having some minor problems
here well then I can shoot him while
he's beaming oh do my teammates are down
no wonder like why is he like training
on Muni 200%
Rep you'd get URI ha I'll take his fire
I'm sure she'll heal me in a second
hopefully
she's fighting on a good place to do
bomb the crap out of the other two girls
I try to get him to shoot over here
while he gets res good thing I got that
vitality
this is not good
oh no I went out when he was beaming
you know
this is not awkward at all alright there
so
yeah we got him jesus said to dump like
all the bullets in the world whoo
do you enjoy this game um I think it's
kind of cool like um there's a lot of
stuff that I don't understand yet and I
haven't gotten a good handle of but I
like the fact that one I enjoy sword art
online so the characters and all that
stuff is already good for me I like that
there's loot everyone that knows me
knows that I'm a big looter loot type of
loot driven type player so yeah Jeff had
his Jeff sign has a pretty good point
it's kind of like a mix of Borderlands
destiny and monster who know a little
bit the boss is that I wouldn't say or
necessarily the heart like the hardest
that one is interesting just because
there's a lot going on but what's up
yellow Sanchez hello Hey look weeps pots
back at it yeah yeah I don't mind that
come join us at weep spot calm I'm also
I look like running out of bullets but
like I said we do have skills got that
like dashing attack they're like sliding
machine gun shot at GameSpot is it worth
buying that was from Allen pears from
YouTube uh I think that if you're a
sword art fan possibly if you played the
other sword art games and enjoy those
and want to just have fun going through
like the gun gale art as well as kind of
like well you know learning some RPG
systems and whatnot
then I think it's worth it but I think
if you're not a huge you know sword art
fan or if you're not into you know RPG
games or a shooting game like this I
mean now granted there's a sword we
could try using a sword here in a second
have no idea what that looks like
let's go back to town see if there's any
new quests otherwise we could just come
back here and to the remnant wastes and
mess around with the different weapons
so you guys can see what that looks like
yeah I appreciate everyone hanging out
tuning in giving me tips being mostly
nice I think you guys have been all
pretty good actually though so yeah you
finish I might not have gotten all the
treasure chest hard to say I've got some
credits up to 20 core I was like 20
hello
Chuck's clan wek oh you're a close
combat player you need a high damage
output high agility low intelligence
high vitality low dexterity a little
luck oh good thing I have high dexterity
what's the best for dexterity then what
weapons the best for Dexter dee Alex
Wynn says at GameSpot how linear does
the game feel so far is it very open ah
I would say it's pretty linear in the
sense that like you know you're talking
to you know your respective important
people for different quests and things
like that and you know once you get a
quest you can more or less go to the
remnant wastelands and you know you go
and do that quest right now by doing the
dungeons we're pretty much upgrading our
office system I don't think there is a
dub retro gaming I never tried I
personally prefer to play everything on
Japanese I don't do English dub so
personally but
Kosta Boda part of any high takara get
myself here Pajarito joka hemos sido una
pareja de
later career I reserved a I called her
Yuri huh but her name is Korea I want to
say Andrey there's been like two other
ones but I'm not 100% sure because I
would assume that like each arc of anime
that's coming out has had a game but not
honey wasn't positive I probably should
have played the first arc of sword art
that ever came out because that was
probably my favorite personally assault
rifles heavy and not heavy and sniper
rifles okay cool so I have one or the
right weapons on then I can go double
they are yeah no worries Alex when I had
a friend in college
he's funny Alex at neig Ewan right she
feels cuter now totally you're super
cute my outfits well I feel like I could
have already changed emotes number one
ratio perfect says metal gear survived
is better that's fair people are doing
that game surprisingly I think I leave
their Christian Lander says I believe
there were four si o games now ok so
what was the fourth Oh was there one for
like mother Rosario though cuz like I
only know the arcs as like you know the
the very first one then alo then GG oh
and then there was like mother Rosario
but again I've only done and watched the
anime as I haven't read those the light
novels or whatever five more parts for
her great as usual
don't mind me just doing some emails
[Music]
sure
sure I don't know why it asks me to give
her a haircut so I guess it just
randomizes her look so now she has a
different haircut and different piece of
gear on
I guess if we're already down the road
of high Dex I have seen by your place
how you like also taking potshots from
me alarms you should choose you should
pick up a semi-auto sniper rifle when
you can okay I'll try that out max rate
cook thank you I guess I can continue to
go down the decks route I guess oops
this all decks all the time sure
whatever I don't care it's not a big
deal let me see if I have I don't think
I have a semi that's new hmm a lupus ooh
what's this this is probably not send me
on a Mac though right it's just a sniper
rifle
I don't give a messing around with that
you see if there's anything else I don't
think I did you can also look in the
shop it's just unfortunate that the
oops they don't sell higher than I gave
her a lot of life and int thinking like
oh she's just gonna heal me I don't know
it seemed like a good idea when I did it
and then I just had to give her enough
like to like wear certain items I don't
know yeah you can have 30 life you'll
just never die
sure oh wait here you can have a better
gun you should definitely be putting on
way more damage now once players don't
go over 30 for their direct stare the
early game since there's no need for it
well whoops I don't know I don't think
there's like a right or wrong way so
it's fine yeah okay dog I don't know I
think our review for Metal Gear survive
will be up I think either tonight or
tomorrow tomorrow Hussein from the UK
offices do handling that I think that
weirdly some people enjoy metal your
survive for whatever reason all right we
got mmm got a new sniper that we could
potentially quit on check that out sure
this is probably better than the one I
equip Wow
424 damage holy crap
shotgun he's the good that we found I
think I don't think it's a very good
though don't see myself using a shotgun
anyways you guys want to see you launch
our gameplay you have a green beret case
your loadout guns I should be able to
help you if I know what you're using
yeah sure let me equip that other sniper
rifle real quick and then so I have this
AR which is I guess not as good as I
thought it was but it's a it's a
legendary so I figured with all these
extra stats it would probably make up
for the fact that you know might not
have the highest damage and right now I
had equipped this sniper but I think we
have a better sniper where's that blue
sniper oh this one I don't know what a
difference between these two are oh this
has double burst there are actually ten
si o games but American release wise
this is a fifth or sixth game one of the
games is a crossover with another light
novel that the creator of sao mein name
also oh I saw Lord yeah I saw the world
yeah I watched that enemy it was good I
actually really wanted to like a second
season but I guess I just never got into
that or never whoa
[Music]
you Millennials are making me cringe hey
man I'm a millennial um so I don't know
can either use this Alamos R or this
sangfroid it seems like it oh it's got
an explosive attack I think is pretty
good let's bolt action which means just
by one shot and then reload and then
this is double bursts accuracy a plus
oops here we'll just try both we'll just
try both I'm sure it'll be fine I just
got to be real accurate one thing we got
it better that's it that has strength
movement speed
keep your primary as a good assault
rifle that you're used to or at least
some sound okay all right that's fair
let's get that that's all right go back
and then we'll change this to that crazy
sniper all right oh it's weird I have to
try to find a quest now or we just have
to keep doing those bounties or whatever
there might be someone in the world to
talk to you so let's go find out they
just made a movie for us I'll world and
keep saying season two it's coming yeah
it's been a long time though Christian
since the first season
so gun Gale online mixed with sword art
online well I mean gun Gale online is
sword art oh I know let's run the same
you know and a light novel anime oh
there's a definitely a quest here
somewhere
seize it I know who's gonna give it to
me somebody unless she's downstairs now
okay we're good
your skill level should have a semi-auto
knob bolt action is slow on your skills
show it wouldn't help you in long run so
sure use that al-nassr then instead they
got some fancy outfit on mean player god
really mean please
so you look at dinner
this game is called a sword art online
fatal bullet and they're bowing that's
what I just said kareha Rhea's sent by
says now personally how much ding I
answer that question without looking
what would you give the game from one to
ten I don't review game so I can't give
you a score I can only base it off what
I said earlier which is like you know do
you like the sword art online world
there's this guy if you like sword art
world or online and the characters and
you want to do like RPG stuff you know
could be a game you want to check out
this guy is a real piece of work to us
the beginning on the beginning but now
he seems like a stand-up guy I don't
know I don't trust this guy dama nearing
player save the timid player okay rule
says I'm about 30 hours in the game and
I could say I enjoyed it a lot but there
is some spoilers to the new alternative
season in April in terms of characters
and personalities ok maybe I can't get
that far oh man I got you the more could
you still cook up
meanwhile say hot dog with flame up
there huh
so okay I see what you're seeing max but
the load out why you better serve to get
that school money mr. Sinise to you just
trying to trying to get our system so
DoD give me that cheese you come on guy
dang see you like look how come here
these two are like the same option yeah
Boca nice we take today Oh apparently
this game is supposed to introduce you
to alternate art for essay oh no I guess
that makes sense man they only have
those bully characters for each key
smugness yeah it's key I'm not a big fan
an eraser I says the game caught my eye
but it's kind of hard to afford some I
suggest you check out soul workers in a
stream it's really good and I think it
should get more support I'll try to see
what that was about
he's got people making the tea give me
that you are dosa Oh Superman 2k I just
beat a boss actually he did not have
materials though so I don't know if you
can necessarily say that part of it's
like Monster Hunter maybe the weapons
our opponent Chewbacca Diwali
[Music]
so okay he's supposed to be like really
top player if you didn't know that
already
that's your mean nice I washed up
big-time one about like this anyone
watching black clover
I got it unlike the motionless now she's
got the hots for him it came in Japanese
we have to skill up Chris 914 couldn't
get past this gaming does it get better
Taylor I'm not sure
GZ O'Neal we did service games top-notch
career high sounds like saber says
frozen Tex saber like like a slightly
deeper voice I don't know I study you
and I like you don't say the Thomas ah I
mean by clover is essentially like
merits but Nick's Naruto right so Jamie
although one day uh yeah Master Chief I
think the first 13 episodes of sword are
probably the best
laughter that's fine it's whatever the
first 13 where is like good real good
oh really the game that banged I named
come in for a black clover spoil
something especially if you watch the
trailer like that's past the enemy hello
ash extreme they also enjoy black clover
except for the extreme scream at the
beginning Gina you should have won heavy
on your team for a support class that
way if you need cover they can do
I think kuraha was a heavy though he has
like launchers and stuff I don't know
we're talking min max at this point max
I'm not even at that point LA and what's
it on could it how come wish only to go
to the Cabana it's exam so seasonal
scored it on you to you know whatever to
preah khan you know
- hang on John Squad fu eats ki
what he's still joined - anyways no we
don't we just wanted me with one of you
at kirito and asuna not this guy uh I
will girl the enemy or they a game cuz I
watched the first season Garo and then
I've never got into it after that
let's change real quick hon just on the
side it's a mole luck well I can't used
all my points
nobody fine go ask your children see if
he gets jealous me Charo bot says hey
smiley face as this is the freedom wars
team and I love that game sherry by this
I didn't play that game himself not too
sure what's some good anime this season
says Killzone 3 1 0 I can tell you the
ones I'm watching I'm not actually
watching that many that are out this
season I'm watching black clover which
if you argue it's like in the second
part of its like I know it's like in the
second of its 13 episodes I'm also
watching overlord season two because
that's finally back I think that's all
I'm watching waiting for my hero Academy
to come back in April the decision
system in here is weird says red sent by
yeah I don't like it's come on like I
don't know go to your friends list via
Start button menu and change up your
team okay you got it
oh crap hold on Joker oh my god
stalk us on stalk us on who knows this
stalker Christian lander Singapore toes
great arch are playing that the boruto
beta this week I could not get in the
beta I just can't wait for my hero
attack on a Titan and OPM one punch man
yeah I'm scared though about one punch
now that they switched what production
companies oh he's salty now I'm see no
it's a friend kono subarashii piece of
comedy I like wanna see Bob but I don't
I think I I watched all of season one
and then it kind of got through season
two but not like super to many of those
Mike overs by the nerd so people it's
going to be a hundred episode anime I
don't wanna get involved with those long
as enemies I don't know I'm like what
chapter like hi to hundreds I think or
mid 200s in whatever we're skipping I
can't I can't do this anymore we hope
they're out I'm hella confuse anyone
else confused oh I finished reading
fairy tale I never watch the anime
it's Allah JJ oh and you couldn't mine
yet
swordart or did he did carousel really
meet sinon & swordart alright this is
what I haven't really don't read that
light novels alright so someone wanted
me to change my party not what they
wanted me to do friends list
oh thanks for the add how do i how do I
get him into my party we need we need
him and asana wow that's hard to say
Allen pairs I don't know if it's worth
it's hard to say it's it's kind of like
you would play a Bunge or like if you
play through the whole thing to probably
take you a while but I don't know I feel
like I would tell you to buy Monster
Hunter first unless you're not into
Monster Hunter gameplay how I alright
hold on I gotta go back and read that
thing the lower sucks not gonna lie you
sure forget about the lower specifically
and just play for the actual game trust
me you'll have much more time I'm just
confused because what I knew is not what
is going on right now so that's why it's
confusing to me alright
go to your friends list via Start button
menu and change up your team it's just
not the front nugget is a friend list
oops okay
yeah we level 38 by God all right how do
I do this how do I change the team I can
swap parallel universe explanation game
is different from the anime it got it
that makes more sense
how long is the screaming going along
like how far is he um
trolls galaxy I would say I'm probably
like three or four hours and maybe a
little bit longer but give or take that
that much time and I started it about an
hour ago probably play for another like
30 to 40 minutes or something how do you
find new designs for outfits I'm not
sure Thomas Connelly I haven't found any
myself you can hide your accessories if
you want oh that's pretty good looks
like arty to change the party member on
the friends list okay how many can we
bring with us oh yes see you later
kareha yes scrub you weren't my best
friend Nick after all all right let's
let's try that out
thank you for the tips how do I hide
this accessory oh there's a little
visible thing so let's see show hide
excite oh yeah yeah yeah yeah our
fashion it's all about fashion right
it's parades ugly oops
no that doesn't really matter yeah
alright fashion we're John week Kirito
as a top player level 3 button yeah well
you know hit our - hey I got there guys
I got there thank you oh we got to talk
to this chick hello she's supposed to be
really strong wears a daisy or whatever
she's supposed to have like a blade type
thing too
later my exhibit in a box yes I need a
new part yes I know there's other zones
how do I get to him okay defeat of us
okay okay so I got to beat the boss in
the remnant wasteland
I thought we did Oh nervous that like
level 28 scorpion oh all right let's go
come on we got new quest be very careful
on who you bring not all the characters
will best suit your playstyle it's gonna
be fine we're we're here for our PE look
for the guy look in the corners for the
guy who sells guns like epic guns really
there's a guy that sells epic guns Jesus
there's too much going on here man how
am I supposed to find this guy hi do you
sell epic guns how about you know you
know it's all the guns is a dish No
does anyone know how to make lots of
money I don't know I feel like I get a
lot of money anyone knows where this
secret epic gun peddler is I'd like to
know otherwise we're gonna go shoot some
stuff here in a second
ooh
I find you attractive all right let's
just go do questions I can't afford him
damn really 300 thousands not enough to
afford him and I feel broke
I need 1.5 million for that three-piece
swimsuit or whatever it is
beat the area boss in the cave all right
I hope I'm high enough level to beat the
boss in the cave I don't know man oh so
chillaxing oh so high a gracious tree
man but I got a run thanks for stopping
by and hanging out for the little bit in
the comment so would you recommend me
buying this because I just might before
the day ends I mean if you're in the
swordart as I had mentioned previously
you like the RPG elements you like the
kind of gameplay mechanics like the
shooting or I haven't tried the sword
yet but if you like all those things and
you want someone that some more story
with sword art then yeah I think that
it's it's right up your alley again you
know if you're not a huge sword art fan
it's probably a little bit harder to
dive into but not not that not terribly
hard obviously if you like all the other
mechanics then sure go for it
but if not and you're weary about all
that stuff I'm sure if you wait a little
bit I'm sure it'll go on sale not too
long from now I don't know it's just a
guess the guy you search is near a
building the doors are yellow okay for
you I'd recommend keator stolen seen on
one close and one far well we got kirito
and asuna
the lovers
why one two nine five says has this got
an online multiplayer mode
yeah um I haven't tried it you can like
squad up and stuff like that I think but
someone said you couldn't go through
story together or something oh I have no
bullets for the other gun whoops
well we could go back and buy gun but do
I want to make you guys suffer through a
loading screen we might actually have to
only because because we're gonna fight a
boss here so sorry
might be guys might be might be might be
whoa Ted Ringel don't you be talking
about sword art being a bad anime you
get out of here with that I don't like
it that's alright it's alright you can
have Europeans Oh No kind of enjoying it
so max are you saying sword art doesn't
really matter in a game like this if you
like a game that is open-world an MMO
and has guns then this is the game for
you yeah that's pretty fair I guess I
think you can date Kirito LOL Kirito
dating Gary toe that'd be kind of weird
no
right we need to get to the lobby now we
need to buy some bullets
raise senpai says the guy that sells the
epic guns looks shady AF what kind of
gun do you want I don't know who knows
I'm just trying to enjoy trying to do
some some big DEP's you know just having
a fun time you know with a stream thanks
for the tips I buy some bullets I don't
even know what bullets this thing takes
sniper bullets just by a little bit of
everything whatever
anti-material bullets even though I
don't think I have an answer I don't
even think I have an anti material gun
right now or weapon all right
that's got to be enough sniper bullets
right that's not enough I don't know how
much whoa Dark Lord one zero six one
saying better or worse than Mass Effect
of drama luckily I didn't play Mass
Effect Andromeda so I can't tell you my
friend says Sao is trashed
tell him to STFU says Dominic rife
Snyder hey Dominic Rice Snyder's friend
Sao is not trash you take that back
everything is better than oh so chill
Erickson says I man thinks just might
for I've watched all the enemy of Sao so
things again and it's definitely not
about anime see a minute thanks for a
stream yep see you later man have a good
homeland god I don't have a Salt River
Boys now what is going on here
whatever we're just gonna roll with it
we're gonna deal with it oh you know
what I didn't skill up my sniper either
can we do that here oh I think we can
who armor form sorry about that guys Wow
we cannot like level anything all right
sure
suppose you're shot that seems good
okay we need to equip the skill though
god it's very awkward to see Kyoto twice
the skill with it we'll deal with
without it for now do not pop shot
sniper's rifle is the way DPS works here
is fair to aim bear the damage okay look
at shiny Oh
awkward BAM
what how is that guy not dead
I got a sniper rifle dang these level
threes are no problem hit that sub and
got your notices on look forward to
future vids thanks man he says game on
this is great
where's that one sniper [ __ ] that's
always up top only my running to other
players too at this point there's
sometimes they spawn I like in this area
if we just shot this as like a like
normal like how much did that hurt for
us does not hurt okay no you dodged it
good job team where's the sniper he's
over there wow this reticle actually
moves I have like a hold breast it
actually moves around a lot again he's a
freaking sort of sick
get him Kitty toe
you only run into enemy and our players
made me sad when I found out yeah hard
controller hit hard like I don't know it
moves around more than I thought it
would I was like a deep breath function
I wonder if that's a thing I bet I bet
there's like oh I bet that concentration
skill probably helps oh [ __ ] easier with
this team assemble
I really need to use the other weapon
just to get they are bored or we can use
the whip thing grab them man he is just
going ham just let my teammates do the
work I'll sit here and reap the benefits
actually I'm not getting any ammo so how
is the game is the game fine ass Bottari
I'm enjoying it so far I I don't have
all the I don't think I have everything
figured out by any means but uh now
these these huge numbers are satisfying
now pop shot these stupid bees though
shoulder charge pop shots
pop shots everything that max told me
not to do
each other like pink oh I'm doing like
nothing real talk
and they will be fine
uh-huh I think asana gives a bus good
sit on her oh crap it's a enemy team
where did you guys come from where is my
team please Wow she made my reticle like
a lot bigger together she's gonna try to
resume matures thanks asana Yuki asana
with that she got cute oh man maybe we
should go sword man damn all right I'm
pretty sure the bosses in here will see
how we do could be a good way to
potentially check out the new area and
then probably sign out run all right new
dungeon the heel is a skill move so no
magic element in this game right um I
think there are some elemental damage
because there's like explosive or fire
shots and things like that
that there's a heal bullet I'm not sure
about the ability I don't know it seems
like some of those guys have like the
actual abilities to heal so I haven't
dug deep enough unfortunately to
properly tell you but I'm liking this
duel hitting oh crap
have to help my team kind of like sniper
call me me the sniper wolf yeah I'll
take the pop shots I guess I don't know
dude sort of looks like a lot of fun you
don't want your strength I regret
everything I should have been more like
Kirito instead I'm seen on
that yelloweye I acquired a peacock like
a treasure chest
you know what the treasure chests having
been worth it let's just not worry about
them you use this order's accurate oh
that can only make it now you can use a
sword sword is one of the many weapons
that you can choose from
oh I switch weapons I was wondering why
the scope and Wow that actually hurt
boom where is it
Wolf's night boo
sniping not so easy it's almost like a
Widowmaker thing we're like it kind of
like focuses more a little bit once it
gets closer I could be making that up
Wow 1,000 crit all day please look at
human field I think was a dead my B yeah
you can't free realm I don't think with
friends
oh there's a lot of years whereas they
said sniper top gear tail looks like he
doesn't know how to get up they're just
funny Oh interesting game can you dub it
I'm not sure if you can dub it
I can check later a shotgun guy just
jumped down yet another one up there I
think so
[Music]
dude Kirito move you're in the way got
me tonight no idea what that is that is
some good healing as mentioned there's a
lot of layers in this game that I
probably haven't even come close to
touching all of them wow she got
teleported
whoops both my legs there's this game
open-world it's not like fully
open-world I mean you still like go to
like different areas but like within
some of these areas it's kind of like
open-world because you can just walk
around like the remnants waste and do
different things the dungeons are in
there too some of them you new quests
were oh that's not good
what kind of weapon classes are there
says mr. alpha Mac there's shotgun
there's handguns submachine gun assault
rifle sniper rifle launchers Gatling
guns I'm probably still missing sword
face ordering I'm probably missing some
more but so how do you get more bullets
in this game says straight-up reviews by
killing stuff you get ammo but you can
also purchase ammo before you go into a
like a mission or something like that
but killing enemies does like also
there's boxes in the dungeons that give
you more ammo
[Music]
dropping the grenade might be cute oh I
like this back and forth with Austin
makes me feel like I'm with the squad
you know
I screwed up the reload box I thought it
would give you a proposal weapons
acquitted Oh me I only gave it for one
if I can get boats for the assault rifle
I think I used it already I don't think
I can fortunately that's fine
Grenada sounds really good
apologies at the sniping seems a little
boring doesn't do a lot of damage on
three two go
gonna give me nothing serious what the
boss is hopefully we're near it brave
soon seven GameSpot how's the game so
far for you I've had a lot of fun with
this game yeah it's a pretty fun pretty
interesting I wish I had a better grip
or a better handle on the gaming overall
but I mean that's kind of part of the
fun I guess is learning you know the
mechanics a little bit more figuring out
you know kind of min max max Reeves he's
been giving me some good tips and chat
so if you have a good chat or a good
tips thing you guys always have a good
chat but you guys have good tips in the
chat feel free to send those over and
just trying to get better you know
there's a red door right now I'm low on
the assault rifle ammo which you can't
do anything about wasn't supposed to do
[Music]
oh it's freaking man
using my way
yeah I think I should have one sword out
of him
treasure box rusty fragment that's what
I imagined tears oh it's a to me nice
play I'm essentially be seen on of this
group massive damage protip shoot their
weak point thank you yes I am definitely
trying to shoot their weak point for
massive damage group but thank you you
just call me max bud calling me by my
full name is too far well that's fair oh
so we're on that friend anime level
where I can
I got a damage of this weapon though
like a it does double hit you come down
here to fight my teammates also the two
bullet thing that helps me kind of like
like I can kind of get away with
dragging a little bit so having my
recent ones which is good oh it's like
what happened No
so yeah you have this grapple what thing
that helps with movement but you can
also do damage with it and with like
some certain monster types you can
actually like pull them down to the
ground which will like you know make it
so that you can that's ok here we go
here we go okay I think I'm gonna reveal
my secret what's the secret
how's the multiplayer I haven't played
too much multiplayer yet Sofia Rio so
just been going through story I really
like some more they should give you like
an ammo box here at the boss feels bad
man it's a shooting something beige
[Music]
this is good
here you go Opie
[Music]
no that's my job
are you
I'll do it just get out of here Nissan
[Music]
oh he's down
oh yeah go ham thank you for status and
he's getting his status down oh not
today
it was so good having carries all this
just getting in there you know
distracting oh oh he's doing a change
out now
thousand 48 so 15 god accuracy not about
spamming
dang easy peasy lemon squeezy what did
he drop Monster Hunter
give me your tail right we unlocked a
new area we required Big Bear I don't
even know what that is but that sounds
cool big bear oh that's right like a
Gatling gun isn't it is there any PvP
there is PvP against AI I don't know if
this TVP against players that would be
kind of cool though if there was there
might be chat might know better than I
do
oh yeah new area unlock Oh unlock dull
you need to learn to switch between
weapons when the enemy is close or far
yeah I mean I would have switched more
max but the problem was my assault rifle
I only had 50 bullets like almost the
whole time so I was kind of hamstring
didn't using the sniper only you know
which is obviously not ideal but you
know sometimes you just don't get to get
that choice
thanks for bugging me saving new area C
so like right now I only have 50 bullets
so that's why I was relying on the kind
of sniper there is PvP against players
oh thank you Goku DB xenoverse for that
one we got some got some killer Hornets
guys are so annoying hook one what do we
get unopp raised item there's a
multiplayer pvp with two modes hero mode
and player verse boss versat player oh
right
where two teams try to fight for the
four like a boss right to get the loot
that's actually pretty cool that reminds
me a lot of a mmo's like back in the
world of workout days where you like you
know fight for like a world dragon or
some Frank that
these guys have a lot more life than all
the other stuff
enemy ah
killer Hornets everywhere and yeah life
and this is new everything in this area
so part of me while we explore a little
bit
I think the rewards are set for boss and
they're all Mets okay Big Bear sounded
like a weapon though or something that
was not just a material but we'll have
to take a look as I mentioned you can
pull them down is it easier to like
[Music]
right here right I probably need some
luck to get more crits co-op for now is
boss only fights okay that's that's cool
though I still like that concept
[Music]
no problem thousand damage anything that
draws from the box will be weapons and
material sweet I only got a big bear
that doesn't seem that great your hammer
right now I just showed my secret big
bear is a weapons this Krishna Leonard
thank you I don't know where the seeker
was I if you haven't seen dude I've
actually never played this gonna just
know so much about these sorts of games
that I know how to read they're just
well okay that's fair I mean I mean all
of it seems logical so that's all that's
all that really matters right but I
appreciate it either way who is that guy
good offer
no problem love sword art online says
help helpless TV thank you I enjoy quite
a bit to still think about the first 13
episodes were my favorite by far but I
still like the other stuff
man where is like the exit for this
thing
this was huge
wonderful find like another dungeon see
a little blue warpgate thing over there
sort of
[Music]
technically kyoto is her master because
i'm few job but whatever
[Music]
[Music]
no problem
Oh head protector that's in you I want
to see some of these new items now that
we're in a new area I also want to see
what Big Bear is my guess is like a
Gatling gun or something though
[Music]
[Music]
that was a dash attack if you're curious
certain guns have like I think SMG &
assault rifle have that tackle attack
and then it also has a ship graveyard
oh he's not dead
[Music]
[Music]
no I deal with that careful it was but
he look like he did like that teleporter
like a boon Sheen
[Music]
oh [ __ ] treasure box
I got dude
[Music]
right there shows a sniper Oh framerate
is definitely dipping in this area
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
yeah there's no microtransactions to my
knowledge so you're worried about that
for that crazy-ass combo we just did I
think I could get that one too oh my god
like crit did nothing to that guy
Oh what the hell is that overgrown
serpent that's not good
you think he's chasing me where is he
just down there
worms nest hey come out come on I don't
think we want to fight that right now
well get out that best stats for someone
who's trying to be a healer I would have
to assume in probably pretty important
right cuz like that lowers your cool
down on skills
Wow I don't do Kirito is going ham we
gotta go we should have went sword fight
her think we reached the edge of a map
what do you think we should do should we
like try to fast travel out of here
should I fight the worm here we'll try
to fight the worm briquette
it's got to be in here right that's not
even the worm oh there it is you think
that glorious bit would
oh hello show that baby worm oh is it
[Music]
you think it would be like Chloe bidding
there
he's got a lot
show me your mouth fine don't show me
around
I got sound horrible be shooting poison
everywhere that's why curious of killing
those things will do anything for us
the smaller worms
[Music]
well that's killing the audio huh hey
optimization game I know this is not
ideal but I don't really have a choice
right now because again low on a are
bullets is a scrubbed and buy enough air
bullets to begin with that smaller one
there's a big guy
Oh Oh my dad and her
poisoning it up everywhere right not
worth killing the smaller ones right I
mean other than the fact that they are
kind of spewing stuff out don't know
where their weak spot is
well ninety holy smokes
good job to you sir oh crap
shoot the yellow spot I stink
no no it's trying that it didn't work
we're talking about like where his like
sort of like his throat is right because
you would think it'd be like oh there
you go it's somewhere in his mouth looks
like come on I killed all your little
babies
[Music]
definitely like in his mouth
not sure where it is not that were like
oh maybe they yellow
[Music]
should probably anymore but I figure
he's moving around so much I try to
advantage in
I would love to crit is not a happening
right now
so these little guys I have to kill them
just to get the big guy to show back up
I don't need to be aiming on those front
of the head dead center okay I think
that's in his mouth the big glowy orange
but he doesn't have it open for very
long so you'd also think he'd be like in
the throat area this way
I say were saying like his forehead
today
[Music]
they have tactical role like this with
weapons to try to get it
yep
you guys asked for this right yeah yeah
the top of his mouth like his forehead
but
back to alright I am at this point
oh [ __ ]
just one more bar you can do it says SIA
horn ah yeah we got it it's just an
inevitability thing
right
because everyone just cherry pie
[Music]
this is kind of reminding me loss behind
a little bit
thank here Joe is like kinda useless
right now
that's in you I don't that it's not
poisonous electricity I guess
oh it's so close to dying Oh hurry not
that book
got'em got him coach which call duty is
this a shadow hentai it's anime TV oh
right okay that's scary unopp raised
launcher know what disorienting alright
how the hell do we get out of here
speed boil
enemy Girl Meets go tiger yeah crap
[Music]
we are surrounded by scorpions
[Music]
this game really gonna be worth it um I
think it's up to you if you think that
what kind of game play you want out of
it it is like an RPG with gun type the
helm hints I guess because we're
shooting Pisces or sword road now we got
so much stuff seven didn't said seven
deadly sins was terrible says Christian
Lander I thought it was okay I enjoyed I
thought it was fun I don't know it's
more mindless than this I guess this has
more layers obviously if you press r3 in
any direction you roll yeah I know I was
also doing the just dash or anything
geez there's a queen wasp now there's so
many enemies in this area
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I like it stand in one place so I
can snipe you brilliant this game is fun
and a level cap this 150 G's 150 all
right probably look at the map so we can
get out of here
you're inspiring yourself a deicing a
lot or not I just I guess I just tend to
80s a lot which is not necessarily a
good thing
all right let's see if we can get out of
here level cabins on 50 yet the top
player Kirito someone was like level 30
the funny thing is eats it skis like 38
at the moment what's on the screen looks
like a third person in borderlands kind
of a little bit
oh I have to go to the dog machine when
I get out of the solitary Sansa is there
like another city that I'm supposed to
go to I thought I could go back to the
beginning and then just like you know
come we're at a to gameplay over
graphics always this looks pretty fun
yeah it's pretty fun
watch out are you reading apart from the
twitch 1s ash extreme I'm reading the
YouTube chat as well so is there like
combos you can pull off because this is
really looking like anime duty as long
as you shoot you win
can you cog eight there are different
lose oh my god the worms back alright
we're not we're not messing with that
right now I have this move which is like
a tackle I have this move whoops which
is like a you know sliding machine gun
move and each weapon unlocks like kind
of different skills that you can talk
all in here we all have this like
speed-up ability which is pretty nice
but you can make that like a like a
thing where you can't it be a tank and
potentially pull aggro and you know be
the one to take damage
so I'm sure there's some type of
potential convoy you are meant to go
back to town we get to a new area all
right so I just gotta keep progressing
forward then I'm guessing by like a new
town area or whatever
I got the deluxe edition on ps4 and I
love the game says Jeff's here at cool
pressed back when you go into the met
you need a skill which allows you to do
huge your mind a majority rifle oh my
god the wasps are back this is
ridiculous
it's never-ending alright there's a
lighthouse lighthouse is good right
shows your blocks oh hello just
Oh
Oh what the hell exact thing they got
mixing this game what the [ __ ] he's a
level 58 sniper butterfly what it was
that he oh my god
please no are we in like the wrong area
right now cuz holy Frick I'm tickling
him that's pretty cool though I want one
of those how do I get one of those
[Music]
good news I'm tickling him
oh god he just hit me for a freaking
thousand damage no I tried to kill Kitty
toe you're the top player what are you
doing sir revised fan my dad yeah okay
well there you go
well we found a way out I wasn't the way
we wanted to geez
we got rekt that's up well Gigi
hopefully yeah I mean I did not expect
you know to run into a robot sniper that
kid almost nieghbors will one-shot you
regardless so I mean we definitely
couldn't take damage from him but he was
a level 58 like 24 you know it's fine
alright we're gonna go on ID some of
this stuff and take a look at some of
the new stuff we got then we're going to
probably call it extreme but I do
appreciate everyone hanging out and
chatting talking swordart also talking
game seems like there's a lot of people
interested which is cool so I know that
wasn't necessarily the best
representation of the game but I think
he had a general taste of it so you know
this warped his room behind home see
where that takes us to you I like I love
the way they say level up gaining four
levels from dying hey I killed a lot of
stuff bunker rock upgrade your damage
and luck well there's not an actual
damage right it would just be like more
decks or whatever I probably just need
to put more luck right now to get more
crit
I wonder have to do the whole like
dungeon again just to do that that would
be real pain in the butt all right let's
get that look up right because it gives
crits you know 15 luck more Dex 32 X 20
luck whatever sure all damage all the
time we gotta go to again mr. Eagle
general Tsin it's kind of single-player
but you can also do something like
online stuff but it's mostly
single-player yeah as syukur na said
when is the Overlord game who knows who
knows my money call me snake sturdy iPad
oh this launcher cost a lot to under
praise God be good right maybe we'll
give it to Korea 756th damage
holy smokes it's limo contest yet
you get anything else like good just a
lot of unopp raised idly what are they
you know I'm crazy sword he cut me is it
I see you wanna God if I will take the
creo hey what else yeah we got like big
bear or something it's Big Bear where's
the big bear impact I don't know about
that bunker comment is a rocket launcher
peacock is a new shotgun
I guess semi-auto shotgun all rifle
called the robust another robust okay oh
yeah I was a Gatling gun I called it
dang it who needs a Gatling gun you
haven't gotten any legendaries I've
gotten one legendary and it was a it's
the assault rifle I'm using I got a lot
of epics I give that to Corey Hado this
rocket launcher look at try it like well
how do you like upgrade your weapons I
have two unequip it to do it seems that
way which is kind of like weird
you see if that's the case
what's the Beth can you upgrade my
assault rifle formula 200 required for
dam formula 3 we'll just go with formula
1 because this could be a bad idea
whatever for science
oh ok see this is what it would do to it
it would give me more damage it seems
not bad it's a lot of parts to give up
though huh shotguns are the way to go if
you need help in the future friend I'll
make sure to look out for your shames
thanks max oh the legendary why not
and we quit Barney little spankin new AR
ok you can see like just how much stuff
you know you could be looking at a shoot
is at the top isn't it and we just like
started - oh there's a plus a plus on it
we just unlocked like newer tier of
weapons and stuff so you can see how it
gets you know deeper in terms of like
this stuff you're gonna be using to use
a Gatling gun if we wanted to guess we
don't have no strength and equip this
rocket launcher every but yeah for you
guys are curious that was sword art
online fatal bullets it's out so you can
go ahead and buy it if you want to
believe as many in chat said it's ps4
Xbox one PC
well that's $59.99 I would assume I'm
pretty sure but thank you all for tuning
in and thanks for all the tips from
everyone and hanging out stay tuned to
anime spawn as I try to find more anime
games to play there's there's definitely
more coming out this year I think attack
on Titan is gonna have a game that's
coming out I think my hero Academy game
is coming out this year maybe that one
piece
more open world games coming up this
year so I'll definitely be trying to
play and get through some of those so
stay tuned to that but until next time
we'll see you here tomorrow we got more
streams coming away this week every day
11 a.m.
oh it's $49.99 according to CC x-ray I
should double-check that when we get you
let me get you the right price here so
that I don't say the wrong thing
someone's at 50 on PC yeah 50 on PC so
where is $59.99 for the oh there's that
thing that sniped me that robot he's in
a picture never saw him until today
anyways thanks guys see you later
[Music]